as preparations continue up and down the  strip for next week's nfl draft we're  also learning who's going to be  entertaining the massive crowds that are  expected so starting thursday rock band  weezer will take the stage following  round one of the picks then on friday  chris angel and ice cube will be in the  spotlight and then on saturday  marshmallow blue man group pif the magic  dragon and terry fader along with  absinthe they'll be performing at the  draft theater at the link and then on  the same day other acts like  jabbawockeez the cast of cirque du  soleil's mad apple and some other local  acts are going to take over the red  carpet stage that's the fountains of the  bellagio so these are all free to watch  lots of fun activities happening next  week